Speaker 1: Before we get into the meat of today's
show, I want to briefly address something here at
the top that relates to something we've been
talking about for years, about what makes it
into the corporate media narrative and what
doesn't. And one of the things I've told you
many times before is that stories with a good
beginning, middle and end, a clear beginning,
middle and end are much more likely to be made
stories by corporate media. And so, for example,
when we talk about shootings, a particular
shooting where we have the shooting is going on,
they've captured or killed the shooter. What's
the back story on the shooter? Thoughts and
prayers are sent. The victims boom that it's
done. Okay. The bigger story of the constant
and I mean almost daily mass shootings in
the United States more than daily, in fact,
is less of a story because it's an ongoing story,
doesn't have a very clear beginning, middle and
end. And I can think of no greater illustration
of this than the fact that since the shooting
in Uvalde, Texas, last week, since there have
been 17 mass shootings in the United States, 17
more shootings since the Uvalde, Texas, shooting.
You can read about them if it's you know, it it
is depressing reading. You can read about them at
gun violence, archive.org. And you will see that,
for example, over the weekend in Philly, there
was a mass shooting where two people were killed
and two people were injured. In Henderson, Nevada,
seven were injured in a mass shooting in Phenix,
Arizona, there was a mass shooting where one
person was killed and five people were injured.
And you can just look at the list. And as I've
said before, every single one of these is its own
story. You know, you can look at the Henderson,
Nevada shooting, for example, and it pops up
a Facebook page, or it will eventually from
the Henderson Police Department explaining
what happened. And there was a reported shooting
and police and fire responded and on and on and
on. Every single one of these is a story and
it is a constant, and that's why it's not as
big of a media story individually. Any of
these might make news, or they might not.
Most of them have at least a local
news article that's written about it.
But consider everything that's happened in Uvalde,
Texas learning about the shooter and what happened
and how they got in and on and on. The victims the
morning. There have been 17 more such incidents
with victims and perpetrators and police responses
and affected families, etc., 17 of them since
Uvalde. The most of us, only the four, most of us.
The last shooting we really heard about was the
one in Nevada, Texas. So it's a it's a story with
seemingly no end. And that doesn't make it a good
corporate media story. But it continues to happen
almost or even more than once every single day.